a local fbi agent was just about a year
into the job when he was called into
work on september 11 2001. thank you for
staying with us i'm brian loftis i'm
denise valdez 20 years later that agent
is telling his story to the i-team's
david charns denise and brian fbi
special agent christopher lamanna has
several reasons to remember september
11th what started as the day he was to
bury his father turned into one
investigating who took down the world
trade center
good morning 64 degrees at eight o'clock
it's tuesday september 11. the sky was
crystal blue there wasn't a cloud in the
sky
and it seemed like the most bluest sky
i've ever seen september 11 2001 means a
few things to christopher lamanna it's
very surreal that 20 years have gone by
it's the day he said goodbye to his
father my dad passed away two days
earlier
from battling lung cancer and the day
terrorists struck his hometown
lamanna now a special agent with the fbi
in las vegas then 29 was about a year
into the job with the fbi in new york
city we were scheduled to bury him
on that tuesday 9 11. a regular
september tuesday
turning into a nightmare some of my
relatives had indicated that they heard
a plane had struck the world trade
center at the funeral paul i had noticed
a number of fbi agents
but when we got to the church they were
all gone soon after he too left his
family said goodbye and got to work i
remember getting home changing out of my
suit
putting on you know other clothes that
were a little more comfortable
because i didn't know what i was going
to be doing i've been inside the world
trade center
so it's very personal
to me because i've walked on the streets
around you know where the world trade
center stood
i had memories there as the towers fell
lamanna rushed downtown i had to go down
there because i knew there were people
down there people that i knew including
his co-worker beth near one of the
towers when it collapsed the debris the
darkness that
enveloped them so quickly
she said she could barely breathe she
saw a glint of an nypd officer's shield
and she grabbed his arm and they worked
their way out of
the area
she was covered
from head to toe she escaped and years
later became lamana's wife
now every september 11th is a time to
remember those moments leading to a
lifetime together moments from that day
and moments with those we've lost i
think about my dad every year
on 9 11 there's a time to mourn but that
was a time for service
i know my dad would have felt the same
way
lamanna has a photo of the new york
skyline with the twin towers at his home
here in the vegas area and he tells me
he spent months working 12-hour shifts
investigating the attacks
and the terrorists he's now working here
at the fbi in las vegas after moving
here with beth several years ago